forget diving hiking and running this
review is for all the Casual people out
there like myself who are thinking of
buying the Apple watch Ultra but not to
run marathons or do any of those extreme
sports Apple showed off in their
marketing this review is for those who
honestly just want to buy the Apple
watch Ultra for one simple reason it's
freaking cool
[Music]
now obviously the cool Factor isn't the
only reason casual users should be
buying the ultra because there are many
reasons that I'm going to cover in this
review which will basically wrap up my
experience with the ultra over the past
week and let me tell you I've never been
this excited about an Apple Watch before
because unlike any of the previous
Updates this is the first time an Apple
Watch ever felt this unique or fresh
because all the other previous updates
didn't really change much the size of
the display for the first time since the
original Apple watch we finally have a
significant redesign that ranges from
the brand new shape with a protruding
flat casing at the top to protect the
flat glass panel as well as a huge and
unique Crown all the way down to the
addition of the crown guard an
additional button on the side and a
redesigned speaker which is much louder
than before this major design change
right here is the number one reason I
upgraded because it feels like a totally
different watch with industrial and
serious styling that I love but it's not
it's still just an Apple Watch and it's
the best Apple watch but before I get
into exactly why I fully believe in that
statement let's start this review off
with some of the simple things that are
unique to the ultra but I absolutely
love so much as a casual user first of
all the night mode feature is absolutely
amazing because it basically gives you
the option to have two totally different
watch faces and you can instantly switch
between them at any moment by simply
rotating the crown and I myself have
fallen in love with the red and black
night mode theme so much that I've been
basically using it exclusively
throughout the past week because it's so
cool and not only that but it has the
added effect of saving extra battery
life because more of the display is
Pitch Black and if you didn't already
know the red LEDs require the least
amount of voltage and power to light up
leading to even more battery life
savings and speaking of battery life
it's so good that my low battery anxiety
has disappeared something that's never
happened before I'm talking two to three
days about her life depending on what
you're doing I'm not even kidding people
with battery life anxiety should
consider upgrading for this reason alone
on top of that the new wayfinder watch
face is honestly the one I've always
dreamed of something that looks more
serious and more like an analog watch
while also packing a bunch of clean
complications no other watch face before
it has impressed me as much as this one
and it's honestly part of the reason why
I like the ultra so much now another
thing I really like about it is the new
flat top design with the flat display
glass which essentially makes this watch
a lot more rugged than before now
obviously I don't do any crazy sports or
anything like that but over the past
week I've already smacked a couple of
things on accident and lo and behold not
a single scratch on the display and now
that I've watched I updates Apple watch
Ultra durability test video where he had
to try super hard to break it I don't
even worry about it anymore whereas
every single previous watch model came
with rounded glass that's fully exposed
to direct hits which always made me
worry but not with the ultra I also
appreciate the extra Peace of Mind
knowing that this watch is rated for the
most intense levels of dust scratch and
water resistance with the 810 H military
standard rating as well as the en 13 319
certification for water resistance so I
can basically take it anywhere I'd like
to without worrying about it and
honestly I have a thing for titanium
metal which of course is the only finish
available on the ultra there's just
something about the durability weight
and color of titanium that I've always
loved so much so that I even bought
Nomads expensive titanium pen which I
find so cool and the simple fact that
the Apple watch Ultra isn't painted with
the Finish being the actual bare
titanium metal means that if you do get
a scratch on it it's not going to be
noticeable like the space black
stainless steel which has silver colored
metal underneath the paint so that's
another reason not to worry about
scratches on the ultra now another
aspect of the design that I like is the
new Crown guard that's meant to protect
the crown but the biggest advantage of
it is that together with the thicker
design the crown no longer gets
accidentally pressed against your wrist
which unintentionally invokes Siri that
alone is a nice bonus now originally I
got the Alpine band which is the only
option we could choose if we wanted to
get it on launch day since the Trail
Loop models were all delayed and
honestly I do not like the Alpine band
at all I can't stand the clasp which
takes forever to put on and adjust and
and the fabric itself wasn't very
comfortable since it allows the watch to
wiggle around a bit on my wrist and
unfortunately I had to leave my ultra
behind when I went wake surfing a few
days ago because I didn't want the
Starlight Alpine band to get wet and
potentially smelly and dirty and I know
Apple has their ocean banned for that
but I honestly hate it it's terribly
ugly and doesn't match the aesthetic of
the ultra at all and if you disagree
prove me wrong in the comments but
thankfully Nomad sent us over a couple
of their sport bands which I'm loving
because it comfortably grips onto my
wrist and the rugged design with these
embedded notches seems to match the
ultra much better than Apple's sport
band now going even deeper I actually
think Apple failed in a big way in terms
of the ultra and that's the fact that
they're only offering three new band
styles with it and none of them are
stylish or fancy for those casual users
out there that want their watch to look
good and that's where these classy steel
bands come in from our partner George
with really cool interlaced band links
either with 100 natural wood or this
unique thermoset material or of course
you can keep it simple with a genuine
leather band so I'll leave a link below
for 25 off site-wide but getting back to
the actually unique features of the
ultra I really love how the display can
go up to 2000 nits because I was able to
clearly see and read anything on the
display even in direct sunlight without
any issues and since the battery life is
so good I don't have to worry about the
extra brightness draining the battery
because of this I was also able to set
the standard brightness to the max
without a second thought and I don't
even have to use the theater mode at
night because of the new night mode
which is even quicker to enable and
disable now to be completely honest I
haven't had time this past week to test
out some of the new features like the
Dual frequency GPS for a backtrack and
waypoints as well as the diving app with
water temperature your readings and the
siren but it's nice to know that when I
eventually do go on a wild camping or
hiking trip or anything like that I can
put those features to use who am I
kidding I don't really go wild camping
but hey those features are pretty cool
for those who do and ask for the action
button at the very least it can turn on
the super bright 2000 knit flashlight in
an instant now yes maybe I'm more casual
than the average Apple watch user but no
one can argue with this last point for
why the Apple watch Ultra is worth it
and that is of course value if you
configure a stainless steel series 8
Apple watch with a 45 millimeter case
size which best matches the 49
millimeter Ultra then the price is
already 750 dollars even with the
cheapest sport band and the reason you
do this is because only the stainless
steel models come with a sapphire
display which is similarly scratches
distant like the ultra seeing as the
aluminum models are known to scratch
easily both on the glass and the case
itself and then if you choose a better
band for the stainless steel model
you're sitting right there at 800 the
same price as the ultra so if you
compare all the feature differences
including the battery life and some
features that Apple didn't mention like
the fact that the taptic engine is quite
a bit stronger and more responsive the
ultra is of course the best bang for the
buck Apple watch of all time and that's
even before considering how the design
is fresh new and likely won't change for
at least a few years making it the
perfect time to upgrade from an older
Apple watch even for casual users like
myself and with that said I don't regret
spending 800 upgrading to the ultra
knowing that it's the most complete
Apple watch model ever made so I'm
likely gonna stick with it for years so
hopefully you guys enjoyed this casual
review and if you did definitely check
out my iPhone 5 14 ProMaster review
right over there and be sure to
subscribe for more videos like this one
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
[Music]